hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast an AHA
checking in on you I'm just checking in
on you how's uh oh Jesus who knows what
how anything is I um I flew today so I'm
whenever I fly I'm a little bit
scatterbrained you know I am a 7 10 a.m.
flight so I had to get up at like 5:15
you know the shows didn't into like
11:30 or whatever I couldn't get to
sleep - like - so my god I got to do is
just make sure I don't miss the alarm
clock
get up get to the airport stumble
through security and then not miss when
they you know board the flight which I
did so I get there and that's it you
know I had myself a little parfait you
know at that guy's [ __ ] restaurant
he's on the chew the guy with the shaved
head I went to his place and uh whatever
I just got the granola what they were
doing that the yogurt and some
blueberries or something like that
vaguely remember so I get on the plane
and all I want to do is just go to sleep
all right so I go to go to sleep
and all of a sudden this [ __ ] guy we
get up to cruising altitude and this guy
you know stands up wide awake like I
sort of got six foot four dad jeans you
know any of these awful shoes these
shoes that you'd wear with the suit you
could tell he didn't want to pack like a
pair like leisure shoes so he just wore
those with his [ __ ] awful dad jeans
and he is just talking loud his [ __ ]
like one aisle up like I don't know
where he walked up from but he was a
couple rows back and he came up he's
just talking the guy gonne figure then
we head to the hotel around 10:30 then
we get the meeting all set up and after
that we can maybe try to decide what
we're gonna do what the game plan is for
after lunch you know any of the other
gotta go they can understand what he's
saying then the guy thing hahahaha and I
just wanted to like [ __ ] yeah God was
his [ __ ] shoes with the two buckles
on two buckles really like how crazy are
your feet that you got to strap him in
to that level you know could they have a
mind of their own so he finally walks
back he goes to
[ __ ] you when he left so I finally not
off and I'm like sleeping deeply and all
of a sudden I just feel this pressure on
my left arm and and I feel somebody
shaking me and I wake up and it's a
stewardess she's class both my arms no
my own with both her hands like she's
gonna tell us that you know you get in
the crash position or something I just
looked up at her
I can't hear what the [ __ ] she's saying
and then I realize that my headphones on
so I just take the headphones off I was
like what well what's what's the matter
she goes did she want breakfast today I
[Laughter]
mean yeah at some point not what I'm
sleeping I didn't think they did that I
thought the only time they did that was
when you know if there was like an
emergency like I'm sorry I know you're
sleeping but you got to bring your seat
back up because God knows you know
that's so [ __ ] crucial to the level
of injury you're gonna have at 37,000
feet right I know it's kind of hacky
material but that's what you think right
she woke me up to see if I want a
breakfast and I was just laying I hope I
wasn't an [ __ ] I was like no I gotta
get a hat that says I had a [ __ ]
parfait just let this old man sleep so
um I don't know I just then I couldn't
get back to sleep so I started watching
this season of The Ultimate Fighter and
uh I don't I mean I know I've seen most
of the season I forgot about this guy
there was this guy the [ __ ] was his name
I can't remember but he just he was like
in line to win the thing and he got
completely hammered kicked out the
windows on a limo you know he just went
crazy and uh he got kicked off the show
and completely I guess blew a shot at
being in the UFC so but he didn't quit
he just kept fighting he's had like 40
fights since then so they got this big
build-up sort of the redemption House
this year where it's people that you
know were in it before and maybe didn't
win I think that that's what it was like
I said I was half asleep so I was
watching his
watching his whole pre-fight versus the
French dude who you know was good with
the kicks and [ __ ] and I'm watching this
stuff and what's weird is to cut into
the guy you know who got kicked off the
show in one of his ears he's sticking
out so much further than the other one
like and what kills me is the early part
of the training it isn't so something
happened to him during training like
what what the [ __ ] happens to those guys
ears I understand like all like the the
fluid in him and stuff but this thing
was just like I mean I can't it was like
Mickey Mouse ear yeah like one of those
sticking so I got a straight out like it
was siglent
to make a left and the other one you
know sticks out a little bit but not
that far and they never addressed like
what happened he said some cool one
point he said yeah you know he goes I've
been around the world I got the scars to
prove it and I'm gonna go in there I'm
just gonna beat this guy down and that's
exactly what he did and I was one of the
few times I was excited that the mic the
gate wasn't ready when we landed that's
always the big jerk-off you know when
you get in early to the airport
congratulations were in 15 minutes early
unfortunately our gate is not available
of course it isn't because they weren't
anticipating us being there and then
there's no place to go you know they
should have like a little [ __ ]
ice-cream thing down at the end of the
runway
you know you peel off onto a little
taxiway you know honey it just gets a
little [ __ ] Sunday or some [ __ ] we
just basically the guy said he's gonna
bring they're gonna bring us to a I
believe you said desolate part of the
airport I know LAX well enough at this
point what they did they just we just
did a lap around the whole thing we
landed on the whatever the [ __ ] it is
the south side of the [ __ ] Airport
and we just land because that's a side
United is on which by the way I'd like
to apologize to the guy who got dragged
off that [ __ ] flight the fact that I
ever flew that airline again I already
had my ticket I wasn't even paying
attention I felt like such a [ __ ] you
know it's a fellow American that dragged
off and even you know what even if he
wasn't from here because I don't know
where the [ __ ] he was from I think they
said was going to China or some [ __ ]
just human being the human being you
know I just felt dirty riding on that
[ __ ] airline so that that's I think
that's it with those guys you know
unless somebody else does something
worse than them we actually all realize
that United was actually you know they
were actually kind of reserved we
smashed his cheekbone off the side I
think I just can't believe they can make
you get leave like no I'm not leaving
I'm not leaving is the president getting
on well then I'm not leaving plus
nowadays the president has his own
[ __ ] plane to just kill makes like
what about that guy what about his plans
what about his business what about his
loved ones what about all of that [ __ ]
just [ __ ] dragging the guy off is he
screaming that was real I don't know
that was just that was really yeah you
know what kills me is you know goddamn
well the head people at United Airlines
when they looked at that footage all
they thought about was just damage
control they didn't give a [ __ ] about
that guy I don't know am I out of my
mind that should not have happened in a
first world country that was just like
some overthrow the government there's no
rules anymore Jesus Christ I mean they
just [ __ ] manhandled that guy like he
did something you know what he did he
paid for his seat that's what he did and
he got on and he put his stuff in the
overhead compartment he sat down like he
was supposed to then he got his [ __ ]
ass kicked
oh he got roughed up that big boy that's
two minutes for roughing that's what you
would get you know so anyway so I get
back to the [ __ ] LAX I'm still a
little groggy or whatever and I always
take taxis you know cuz nobody takes
taxis out here so they're always
available I just walked right out the
guys there and I got a pet peeve on my
luggage right like whenever you walk up
with your luggage you know the driver
goes to take it what they do is they
push the button in to make the handle go
down about three-quarters of the way and
then they just release it then they and
they just slam the thing down so I
always go just wait a second wait a
second I'm let me just do it and the guy
just kept grabbing for it I said wait a
second
okay look let me go thinking I'm the
dick it's like I'm not the dick all
right so once you [ __ ] mess up the
handle once you mess up the [ __ ]
handle now what am I gonna do carry it
like it's the 1970s I travel like a
stewardess so we get the whole thing
down he gets in the car goes how was
your flight I say it was great and he
goes where you're going I tell him the
address and he goes okay can you can you
[ __ ] type it into my phone
I don't know mine [ __ ] that's odd no
I don't know I want you [ __ ] you
can't [ __ ] do I don't hate once you
slide over I'll [ __ ] drive I know how
to get home um all right Jesus Christ
see this is why I don't do the podcast
110 when I flew that day as I mentioned
because I'm like extra crabby and I had
a great time by the way out in Cleveland
Ohio every time I come back there the
downtown area is more alive I remember
working at hit hilarities for the first
time in 2004 was the end of 2003 I was
doing new year's first time at Jason
Lyon and a bunch of Cleveland guys and I
just remember just looking at the
downtown area and there wasn't [ __ ] down
there I mean I was staying at the
Holiday Inn Express right around the
corner and they had to give me a [ __ ]
escort home
I was literally walking a block in half
and I was thankful that they gave it to
me I did a fast paced walk over to the
club before the show so I remember
looking across the street there was this
big apartment building I remember just
thinking like man if I had the [ __ ]
money I would buy that and redo it and I
would be I would make a fortune on it
and you know didn't have the money and
now every time I go back they should see
it now like like hilarities was the only
game in town there on this dark Street
now you show up it literally Lai think I
said this before looks like the [ __ ]
Bullwinkle show there's a House of Blues
this is place called I don't know some
craft beer places all of this [ __ ] this
gift shop t-shirt store where they have
all this stupid Cleveland stuff they
look like they was soft t-shirts I liked
a lot of them and I actually liked Ohio
but
like the nickname for Cleveland calling
it the land is just it's so bad the land
Pittsburgh the Berg is Cincinnati the
nati
it's so [ __ ] terrific I thought
Beantown was bad I always hated that
growing up in Boston and the Millennials
started calling it the bean so in
Cleveland they have these [ __ ]
t-shirts it says defend the land from
what you seceding from the Union what
are you talking about I was happy for
him you know they won that championship
and all that type of [ __ ] you know and
looking good Jesus Christ absolutely
[ __ ] destroying the Toronto Raptors
you know I was gonna say I had a theory
about the you know if you name your team
after some [ __ ] movie [ __ ] like the
Anaheim Mighty Ducks the Raptor as we
all know that's from Jurassic Park like
you're never going to win a championship
but goddamn ducks did but they had to
stop being the Mighty Ducks I mean when
they first came out there with a Mighty
Ducks say the exact same uniforms as
those little kids which is basically the
Bad News Bears on ice and then they
would up on the diamond vision they
would have like Emilio Estevez it
clipped from the movie of him giving a
rah-rah speech to a bunch of children
and I'll tell you when they actually won
a cup after that [ __ ] that really hurt
me as a Bruins fan going like did we
lose to a [ __ ] team named after a kid
movie I don't know so anyways they've
been kicking the [ __ ] out of how about
the Celtics Celtics continuing to
[ __ ] move through the playoffs up two
games to none against the wedeck come on
in he's out there he's on down the roll
hold I can't believe it the Boston
Celtics brand of basketball other than
their refusal to quit I cannot [ __ ]
believe that we're winning we don't get
any rebounds we're soft in the [ __ ]
paint we live and die by the three I
mean that with that right there that you
tell it's just a deaf ear
somehow you know I never going to run to
that you know if we get by The Wizard
you never know what the [ __ ] happen
but when we run into that Cleveland
Cavalier buzzsaw that's that's just
going to be it it's gonna be a we we're
not gonna have enough [ __ ] answers
huh Kelly Olynyk trying to cover [ __ ]
up Bron James or Al Horford what's he
gonna do he's not gonna [ __ ] you know
um anyways I mentioned a couple podcasts
ago that uh my wife had gone rogue when
it came to the DVR and all that and I
promised that she Alba talk to her about
it with you guys hey your requests on
the the podcast you request you know
your your your presence is requested to
is why I don't do Ponte doughnut when I
fly um yeah you got a mic you got
everything there you go alright now
we're gonna have to have a nice measured
conversation don't touch my luggage
that's why I never have guests all right
she's gonna do the whole thing here
who's this other person she wasn't she
wasn't booked what's up baby how are you
hi come on let's get let's get into it
she's fine she's full she's changed um
anyways Nia yes you've gone way gone
rogue first of all welcome on the 10th
anniversary week happy anniversary yeah
ten years credible it is ten years of uh
running my yep no idea where this was
gonna go and now look at me all these
years later I remember sitting in my
jeans and t-shirt yeah exactly like I
was ten years ago I have the exact same
level of Technology I don't have a song
I haven't done anything although you
didn't have a soundboard and stuff
before you just used to like oh yeah
well I'm home yeah you used to call on
the phone
how did that work you you called up some
service huh hey I used to do it when I
was on the phone I would drive around
and I'd be getting arguments with other
people in the cars and I would be at the
airport I just make fun of fun of people
we're gay what gave you the idea to do a
podcast I mean obviously it was became a
big thing 10 years ago but was there
somebody or something that happened that
made you think like I need to get in on
this you know I feel like I didn't
choose podcasting
I feel like podcasting chose me ya know
it was over Bobby Kelly's apartment
Bobby Bobby right I was over there and
he was like dude you should do a podcast
so he just set the thing up yeah I was
like Bobby Kelly [ __ ] Bobby into
technology and I was like that it may be
in the old crabby guy even back then go
do it I don't want to do that stuff just
chill just set it up dude
it's a good way to connect the defense
bro he was right yes he was he was right
he's right on that point in the podcast
you know what he was wrong about her you
know Bobby Kelly was wrong about the
mini CDs mini CD many CDs yeah when
there was regular-sized CDs he talked me
into getting a mini CD Oh I chord oh
yeah like that was going to take off in
and then I had to buy the microphone
that was seven set up like a little tea
I followed him for like two months I
followed him down over the cliff of
buying every piece of technology and
then I just went back to the [ __ ] the
way I was so anyways
yes Sonia what's going on you know
there's all these great shows out there
that we used to watch together well
better call Saul yeah Fargo hmm
meet me at the mall good season to write
all of these great shows yeah
and used to watch them with me and now
all of a sudden not only do you not
watch them with me you kind of erase
them or decide you know it was some
other show not the shows I just
mentioned there was some other show we
started to watch and you decided that
you were over it and you just you just
stopped recording it okay well you know
probably because there's a way to watch
it on like the Roku
or on-demand I for me I can't figure
that out I have showed you that
countless times I know and show you
again but I'm not gonna keep like hey
how many times I told you how to shut
the water off when there's a flood in
the house there's certain things that
we're good at huh oh you didn't like
that did you
no my eye contact really Nia Nia what
what didn't you like about that comment
oh this is getting real this is like
some Wendy Williams [ __ ] right now you
stop staring at me like you're gonna
beat the crap I here to talk about the
DVR and the TV show stuff we were I
think that's what are you throwing that
other evidence out that's what my agent
told me is that what you're doing here I
thought that was totally who to like
flip the script it's not that's not what
I agreed to what white people do not
flip the script we have a misdirection
we changed the subject oh yeah I didn't
I didn't agree to this
I'm here to talk about um television and
just like Billy Bob Thornton on that
radio show and said don't forget my
movie career just talk about my drum
career what's going on with you well you
know what didn't you bother you've
changed I'm not changed I've changed
change well first of all you one thing
hasn't changed is your inability to talk
into a microphone huh sorry I love it
just pointed at the side of your face
I'm just saying now that we got the
little one here yes
well here's the thing bill is that
you're running around all day and so I'm
here with her and so I watch the shows
then because it's like there's not
really much to do you know I'm just kind
of breastfeeding all day there's not a
whole heck of a lot to do with her and
so I watch it and because you're busy
and then at night when we do get time to
watch DUP you watch it for like 10
minutes and then you fall asleep that's
because I can never in the morning time
away I understand that but I
so then I don't get a chance to repair
enough fair enough to get away races you
gotta race it you got to make the
decisions on like what I get to watch
now like well that's it for you if you
fight if you turn on your Roku thing and
download the news so simple like my mom
doesn't the Roku like it's that it's
that easy so I was turning on and off of
faucet outside the house all right well
this has been fun you're not leaving no
one's ever walked off this show for you
what are you doing right now
you keep belittling me about easy it is
you use Roku how is that belittling I
said it's easy you're the one who
doesn't have the people you say well now
now now you said what did I say you said
you even your mother can do it itself to
me a little bit we'll bet you insulted
me a little bit why is my mother
Samantha I'm saying she's not the best
at technology but she knows how to you
know what you say it's easy as what I'm
saying all right you know I thought
there was gonna be a lot of comedy in
this just you are woefully misjudged how
this was going to go no I know I went
rogue I know I did but it's like yeah
here we go four minutes in alright yeah
I mean I just can't sit around waiting
for you to like watch that 10 Meg got
tired of watching episodes in ten minute
increments cuz you fall asleep and what
am I supposed to do I'm not getting the
money yet I'm not tired yet so I want to
finish watching the show I got to turn
it off just cuz you fall asleep and it
takes like you know six weeks to get
through two episodes that's insane I
think you're exaggerating a little bit
I am but the point is that I'm not going
to wait for your ass to watch shows
anymore it's just we're not on the same
schedule so it doesn't it's not really
practical for us to like watch TV
together like that okay so that part of
our relationship so definitely it's over
alright well here's the thing
yeah stop deciding you know being judge
jury and executioner on the death
penalty for the shows that we record
okay and you know what's weird is you
know I had all myself to games and
Bruins games gangly Gordon I they're not
some reason like not three times I
didn't I finished the accusation I know
three times this season I had to go back
to get to start you know I had season
record I had three times I had to go
back and do it and somehow that never
seems to happen in your shows only to my
show so I can only surmise that the DVR
doesn't like me I did not know I contact
change I will look right at you I didn't
I didn't change the recording series for
your sports stuff mmm I never been in
the middle of recording two things that
you like at the same time this is all
there's not enough space you need to
stop recording on one thing and you
never chose my stuff over your stuff no
because it can record up to five things
simultaneously alright you're recording
five things and there's one more have
you gone through the DVR list have you
noted that like 98% of it is your stuff
it's complete lie you just it is not but
yes I do want to bet I'll bet I know
yeah I'll bet you what what do you wanna
bet I don't know what should we bet well
you want to brought it up oh no I
brought it the bet sorry I'm out of
there
I don't know it's just made a
gentlemen's bet okay well you know if I
was dealing with the gentleman oh I'm a
gentlewoman how about that I'm a lady or
hostile you get lady erasing my stuff I
don't appreciate it bill you have Destry
mm yes Patriots games from serene Bowl
from three years ago it's a Super Bowl
we want it but do you go back and watch
it ever why is it sitting there yeah if
that's one thing I know but it's like
four hours it's a Super Bowl I now beat
the Seahawks okay bye are you gonna go
back and watch it eventually okay but
everything else is gone i all the fasts
and Louds i get rid of those I've seen
all of those I get rid all my Bruins and
Celtics to get rid of those there's a
bunch of games a bunch of sports related
documentaries and stuff that you haven't
watched did you don't have time to watch
a lot of the TV which is fine but I'm
just saying that's the reason why I have
decided to just press forward okay fair
enough
we'll listen TV watching I wish you the
best of luck in the future with your
with your TV viewing no with your TV
viewing I enjoyed watching TV with you
oh and yeah it's just an end so okay
well then let's figure out a solution
like how can we get back on track how
can we get this part of our relationship
back on track this is like their I don't
know what can we do in order to get on
the same page now
look if you're bored out of your mind
during the day and you need to watch a
good show yeah by all means do it
whatever I just needed an explanation I
guess that's all right I'll learn how
tell you what I'll learn how to use the
Roku and you learn how to shut off the
water the next time one of these old-ass
pipes burst what why is it such a big
deal me why do you keep bringing it up
and you're trying to like humiliate me
and embarrass me it's why I'm bringing
it up because every time you talk last
year we had something happen like that I
turned off the water I didn't I called
the plumbers and they came the very next
day yes I did so I'm tired of you making
it seem like I don't know what the hell
is going on okay I was here by myself I
was wrong baby
yes I turn it up under the sink I did
under the sink you turned it off I did
nothing about crazy-ass flooding that
was going on so I cleaned up by myself I
must've walked you out all many times
it's a little valve it's like it's blue
it's the color of water it just turned
you this hose you know why who was that
easy I could do it I forgot to do that
part okay I know Misso and I called the
plumber and they told me that it was
fine and it was fine uh I know because
we got lucky we get knit it's not you
made a judgment call going you know it's
coming from there I would take it out
from the front of the house you didn't
you didn't do it what I was going there
you aren't I saw it in your face did you
do all you do whenever stuff like that
happens when you're on the run yelling
is give me should have no I will not you
just give me [ __ ] about it over and over
again instead of being like I understand
you were alone you were panicked you
don't handle it situations
thank God everything was okay thank god
you're okay thank God the baby's okay
Jesus quite a dam didn't break it's all
we gonna drown that I did wrong and how
I didn't add the way you would have
acted you know I think we learned here
you know I think I we learned I don't
appreciate it okay I suppose afridi know
anything you know hey you guys listening
as we wanted you wanted to flip out are
you not entertained here's the thing
poking me and poking me about it that
was a month ago now like let it go
you've completely lost your composure
yeah cuz you're pissing me off
alright you know what I learned in this
conversation nothing knowing you gulia I
have learned that I'm a little bit
better handling criticism than you are
no you are not listen no you are the
most sensitive jackass I've ever met my
butt I only took it okay fair enough but
I only took it to tit for tat you said
Roku and so you're petty too okay so I'm
petty but I mean I'm not the one yelling
and flipping out here I am a passionate
person and when I am feeling a smell
with the euphemisms oh I finally
euphemism as it is so what are you
permitted is it's a nicer word for being
a douche
[Laughter]
[Music]
instead of saying instead something
instead of saying yes I did just like
you know who to write they'll make
weight now - Rob's a dick right you're
right
no it's like instead of saying shell
shock you say post-traumatic stress
disorder um instead of saying innocent
people died you say collateral damage
that's a euphemism oh all right okay so
there you go so that's saying that
you're an angry lunatic you say you're
passionate I'm not
you're the angry lunatic oh and all
agree not me I am NOT I am the steady
easy one oh yeah really yep yeah you see
her that's crazy what you know when I
had to threaten to bike if you hit me
one more time during an argument I'm not
going to go out with you anymore
when I met you you were a listen as they
were a French mower and you were here oh
my god you just have you got a run for
office for everything I was young and I
was passionate you immature young and
immature and I didn't know how to handle
my emotions and I do now okay all right
I might just check yourself into rehab
that's the other tab and tap not wake
him in the face I need to go to rehab
never punch you in the face you did his
thumb did it on Valentine's Day didn't
push you did yes you did not in the face
the face yes yes it did a face in the
face you did you did I didn't punch you
in the face yeah no I took you that
fancy ass sushi restaurant we were
living in New York I took you down to
that thing and the dude from the phone
booth movie was there right oh I'm in a
phone booth they won't let me leave John
found right he's in that [ __ ] thing
that nice low-budget movie the whole
movie takes place in a phone booth we
love it
low-budget cute Irish guy write me as a
ridiculous well you wouldn't know that
when you the way you were looking at him
in the sushi restaurant you just kept
looking at the guy which was fine for
the first you know ten minutes then
after a while you're just looking at
another guy while I'm paying ten times
what sushi should cost me she was so
exaggerating what happened I wasn't
staring at Colin Farrell the entire what
do you validate my feelings yeah I
believed there was a song written about
everything you've said on this podcast
back in the 80s it went something like
this last yeah yeah the bigger the
better
that was a Thompson Twins how long how
long had we been dating before that
incident I don't know but what ended up
happening was I got in the cab
and I bought it with the cab driver and
I just said go bake buddy let me ask you
a question
stuck my big head through that stupid
little window I go if you took your
woman out on Valentine's Day pursue she
all right famous guy walks in how long
do you give her to look at the famous
guy before after what army out are and
then public everything that long wow I
never thought of it that way
I mean farming held I don't know what I
mean I was young I had I had to get some
sort of victory out I was trying to
merit Eli no I was trying to make you as
upset as you made me and I did it a
little too well because by the end of
the night we were back with him in the
apartment and you came running out of
the bedroom because of course I'm
sleeping on the couch of course I'm
sleeping on the couch I wasn't looking
at anybody else and I paid for the move
for the meal
of course I end up on the couch and you
said something like that some about
bitching or something I said yeah well
you're acting like one and I never
called you that word no sir just two
little feet high floor was not in your
the word don't question that was not the
word in question and you know it was it
douchebag no it was not and you were
saying why didn't you speak into the
microwave such a you know what
and I Lana like [ __ ] no I did you do I
didn't know I did this is what I said
what did I say I didn't I would never
say no cuz that's calling you one which
I've never done never did that yeah you
kind of did in there one time no I
didn't you know you like to disguise it
behind acting like a see this is the
thing can I tell you something there can
I tell you like tell you something me
acting like I didn't say you were a
you're acting like a fair enough but
here's the thing that I've been with you
for 14 years you have two incidents
despite your behavior how many time you
know what for those two incidents how
many times did you hit me I mean that
time you came in you through my laundry
all over the living room you week it's a
frigging psycho yeah I remember that
bunch of fluffy white socks and
underwear like oh my god
[Laughter]
other example your passion I've showed
unbelievable restraint dealing with a
woman like you oh yeah a woman like me
yes yes well congratulations you got a
beautiful baby out of it no that's right
oh we had a good time
yeah we had a nice run well now it's all
about her and evidently we're just gonna
be watching separate stuff on TV no we
can't be that couple we have like you
know still remain at eight I have to say
most times I fall asleep at night
because you're watching those those
women yelling at each other
I hate those shows no I know I do I know
that but we could be watching anything
and you'll fall asleep because you do
you get up super early you're really
busy throughout the day it makes sense
so I get why you fall asleep but I'm
just saying like it's hard to watch a TV
show with you that way that's it okay
all right listen it was nice talking to
you I love you know is that it do I have
to leave now well I mean I got to read
some advertising if you want to sit here
and listen to that oh Jesus mm I know
you listen you read out loud
don't let her listen to that either
because they don't even hope she doesn't
get that for me
get what your inability to read out loud
you know what is this my brain goes too
fast I found if I slow down when you
read to her it's so cute and so lovely
oh yeah thank you guys on all this I
actually I rehearse before the podcast I
read the advertising to my daughter once
upon a time there was a company named
loot crate all right be the envy of your
friends and get 100% exclusive crates at
Luke rate calm / / and enter my code
Barbie you are are to save $3 off any
new subscription mais loot crate theme
is Guardians the best surprise you know
is coming what the best surprise you
know is coming isn't it the best
surprise is that you know it's coming or
is this the best surprise you know is
coming
III need to liver this line you do a
surprise you know is coming that really
annoyed me how easily you know is coming
we'll be right back with more Dancing
with the Stars loot crate offers an epic
range of pop-culture items for less than
$20 a month that's right if you're more
of a fanatical fashionista then try loot
where Method Man come out with that
monthly wearables and accessories with
cult classics and your favorite
franchises in mais loot crate you'll
find items from guardians of the galaxy
to Star Wars destiny and The Goonies
Jesus they're all over the map
one minute you're in space next thing
you know you get a bunch of dirty face
kids coming at you one lucky subscriber
will also win a mega crate including a
Premium Format Groot figure gr OoT
whatever the hell it is from Sideshow
Collectibles guardians of the galaxy
guardians of the galaxy is it's from
guardians of the gals that was like a
sentient filling an actor and appleís
wig and act act nor actor him thanks
how do you say that word acronym an
acronym yeah no I don't know is that one
it's like mad mothers kids drinking and
driving is that an accurate pack nor him
I can't say it I'm sorry I know what it
is Joe quit I honestly am i joking I
can't say that word that is over 20 2.5
inches tall is why I suck at Wheel of
Fortune can't say the words I'd like to
solve the puzzle that's an example of an
acronym oh we're sorry bill Oh God you
have until the 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific to
subscribe and receive that month's crate
go to Luke recon / / and enter my code
bar to save $3 off on any new
subscription today
look who's back everybody know coos back
it's all zip McCarter a them didn't harm
either are you hiring well I do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates now you don't post your job
in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates wake up I love this
copy just slaps you in the face if you
want to find the perfect hire you need
to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can find candidates in
any city or industry nationwide just
post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to zip it is easy to
use interface why don't they do this
with other people you know what I mean
like if you're missing something if a
dog's missing why wouldn't you just post
it there's got to be a zip recruiter for
that right try to get felons or
something just saying you could you
could branch this out no juggling emails
or calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast look at the gams on her
you're hired
lady ladies please send head to toe
photos find out today what zip crew has
been used by Fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses and right now my listeners
can post jobs and zip recruiters free
for free by going to zip recruit accom
cyber that zip recruited calm / / one
more time time to try for free go to old
zip comment / / alright last one
LegalZoom come on in Zoom Zoom Zoom aah
zoom remember that's where Ghana
zuma-zuma Zooma zoom I kind of come on
give it a try a little performance we're
gonna show you just why we're gonna
teach you to fly hi come on in zoom
come on in Zoom Zoom legalism
five things owners can count on from
LegalZoom neverwood reliability more
than a million people have already
trusted LegalZoom to help stay
at their business in corporations LLC's
nonprofits DBAs and more use LegalZoom
to get started the right way number two
[Music]
experience you can count on LegalZoom
for all the details I've got it honey
they've been helping all types of
business owners for over 15 years number
three helpful support I thought you I
hate when people list [ __ ]
I get it you're great can we just get to
the selling point here helpful helpful
support they have the right people
standing by ready for your questions all
base the United States you know that's
kind of that's filler right there as
opposed to what non-helpful people in
other countries well yeah that's kind of
most most companies now aren't they
hello my name is Steve number for legal
advice Legal Zoom isn't a law firm but
they have a network of independent
attorneys they can reviews they can
review supplier contracts help with your
employment laws and advise you on many
of the hurdles that pop up when you're
running a business and finally number
five no surprises legal that's kind of
sad legalism provides complete
transparency with upfront pricing
customer views and a satisfaction
guarantee and they will never celebrate
your birthday without letting you know
first check out Legal Zoom today so you
know surprises nothing new check out
Legal Zoom today to see how they can
make your life better for you and your
business and don't forget to enter
burpee you are a check out to save even
more legalzoom.com alright well that's
it me what do you think about Sidney
Crosby getting another concussion you
know and then the Penguins still I hope
he's okay yeah still some how come still
being up three games at three games to
one yeah three games to one unbelievable
I feel bad for Josh Adam Meyers he's
really going through it right now his
Wizards are down oh two to the Bruins
and his Capitals are down three games to
one oh he'll be all right yeah I know
it'll be a he'll pull through
all right that's the podcast thank you
everybody for listening and happy
Anniversary happy Anniversary happy
Anniversary happy Anniversary why are we
doing that
cuz it's your your anniversary I thought
you were mocking the end of our TV
relationship podcast server sory what
you just you just go podcast a person
yes I know I don't I don't know why I
still can't hold the microphone in my
hand well you know what Nia here's to
another 10 years you not speaking into
the mic I think you're gonna be doing
the podcast 10 years from now
absolutely I will only be doing the
podcast I won't be acting anymore I
won't be touring I won't be watching TV
and not with me I would just be sitting
in a room doing that stuff you know no
I'll be hanging out with this little
little this little dump cutie pie huh
yeah what's up buddy huh I get a smile
you in a contemplative moment um all
right that's it um hey I have to do my
official sign off here and I can't do in
front of the kid even though I dropped
the f-bomb a couple of times
no idea give me your microphone that you
don't talk into and uh I don't know once
you go watch something and erase it you
[Laughter]
know I think the great Michael Jackson
put it best when he said beat it beat it
open up your mouth and feed it bye
ladies close the door all right that's
the podcast everybody you have a great
weekend your cuts and I'll duh I don't
know I won't check in on y'all talk to
you on Monday all right that's it whoa
wait wait you know we're actually going
to have a little bit of music and then
some of the greatest hits of the podcast
gone by in the last 10 years
oh by the way remember when I told you
to check out that band the night game
remember that well rumor has it
rumour has it that they're going to be
opening for John Mayer John Mayer's got
a big tour um going through the United
States of America's one stop in Toronto
the rest of them all imagine he'll go
around the globe with it because it does
say world tour so this is probably the
first leg of it
and he's got two beds opening up I
forget the name of the other band but uh
I believe the night gate I don't that's
official hope it's official hope enough
[ __ ] everything up for anybody but
out that was a band I told you guys to
check out Davi Lich the guy take drum
lessons from is in that band with a
bunch of other amazing studio musicians
songwriters they sound amazing so if you
do catch John Mayer this summer don't
show up late
don't hang in the parking lot
shotgunning beers or whatever the hell
you kids do nowadays taking your Molly
smoking your meth right whatever the
hell it is you kids do nowadays make
sure you get in in time to to check out
the night game I'm sure the other band
is just as good because it doesn't seem
like Mayer brings any cupcakes out on
the road you know what I mean
like you know sometimes comedians will
do that they'll take somebody on the
road that isn't it's funny you know to
me so they don't bring too much heat you
know but the really funny guys
they don't do that [ __ ] all right but
not me I bring cupcakes out on the road
like Joe DeRosa the original cupcake
he's he Joe DeRosa is the cupcakes
cupcake of stand-up comedy miss that guy
man I got to have it back on the podcast
at some point all right enjoy the music
and the the greatest hits I'll talk to
you Monday
you
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 4th 2009 and I think this is
the 15th time I've tried to do this
podcast as you can tell my voice is a
little bit tired I was just working
Caroline's in New York City and I did
six shows and I think I overdid it a
little bit even though I was drinking
tea you know start doing that drinking
tea with a little bit of honey in it
before my shows doing a little [ __ ]
vocal warmup you know I mean you know so
I can save my instrument I know that's
the gayest [ __ ] thing ever isn't it I
don't give a [ __ ] I have to do it
I also end up sounding like this when I
when I when when I don't do it you know
I don't know it's a weird week in New
York I didn't do anything I just I was
holed up in my hotel like [ __ ] Howard
Hughes that's what I do like the further
east I go the more [ __ ] up it is for
me to get up in the morning to do radio
obviously because if I have to get into
radio station at 7 a.m. East Coast time
that's 4 a.m. my time and that's how we
end up getting sick burning it at both
ends so I started taking these vitamin C
pills because they were freaking
everybody out about the [ __ ] swine
flu which once again turned out to be
nothing
how many flus in a row are they going to
scare the [ __ ] out of us about you know
and you notice every flu it's like like
how did it come about it's always
somebody had sex with an animal somebody
in another country had sex with an
animal which is so real like nobody is
[ __ ] animals in this country you know
I think the CIA puts the [ __ ] out there
just doing some experiments they need to
thin the [ __ ] herd so what they do is
they just put the [ __ ] out and then they
just blame foreigners and then they add
bestiality into it so then it just makes
sense to Joe lunchbox you know you can
just see him sitting around the [ __ ]
canteen truck the Roach coach whatever
you call it in your neck of the woods
you know door the [ __ ] swine flu you
know
well we tell what's his line food do Oh
some guy down on Mexico duty [ __ ] he
[ __ ]
peg he flopped the [ __ ] peg you know
we got plenty of pigs in this country
don't see anybody [ __ ] them those
[ __ ] people in Mexico [ __ ] pigs
doing is just like aids those [ __ ]
some guy in Africa you know he [ __ ] a
monkey and he jerks off the stewardess
next thing you know I got a wet condom
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude we should
close the [ __ ] borders notice that
was all done in a pseudo Boston accent
because that's where I heard most of
those conversations as I was grown up
and when I worked in a warehouse and I
got a mitt some of the times I was the
guy saying them as I went out and I got
a sausage King for breakfast for my
10:30 a.m. break remember that [ __ ] you
worked in the warehouse and you're just
sitting there and it's a Monday and the
day's just [ __ ] Monday's didn't crawl
Tuesday's crawled Monday you was so
[ __ ] bleary-eyed from your weekend
that the day in some weird way kind of
went by quickly you know plus you know
you kind of excited to get back to work
whatever girl there you kind of got a
crush on you're trying to figure out how
to [ __ ] her you haven't seen her in a
couple days so you got that level of
excitement you know you got all that
going on maybe a big your team won the
big game the day before even if they
didn't you got something to talk about
so monday goes by quick but then Tuesday
Tuesday is when it hits you [ __ ] I work
here I hate this this is going to be the
same [ __ ] all over again what the [ __ ]
am I doing with my life and then it just
drags ass I don't know about you guys
but back when I had a real job before I
just did this [ __ ]
I can't even begin to tell you how
[ __ ] long Tuesday's seemed it was
almost like they like the clock ooh it
was like they had like a phony clock on
the wall and every minute was actually
two minutes you know I'm telling you it
went by slow people why did I need to
give that last example I don't know what
but all I know is what I must have
looked at the clock like 85 times before
10 15 when the Roach coach would come in
and it would blow its horn that you know
but I got that but that could dad day it
didn't do that it was something else I
can't remember but it was one of those
[ __ ] fancy horns and everybody would
just remember was lose this [ __ ] was
like the adult version of when the ice
cream truck came down the street member
that old Eddie Murphy bit the ice-cream
man is coming same [ __ ] but for adults
and then I would literally go out there
and I would either get a slice of pizza
off of this truck for those who always
has had a white-collar job you know but
you know those those canteen trucks
right the silver looks like a pickup
truck in the front the back it's all
silver and they lift up the side and
there's all kinds of [ __ ] that's
where the [ __ ] swine flu comes from
god damn it probably those [ __ ]
trucks but anyways then I I would go out
there and I would literally get like a
slice of pizza like this I don't know
who made it you know what I mean where
where was it made and you get that or I
get like a sausage King at 10:30 in the
morning 10:15 in the morning and I would
just eat that thing after boozing all
weekend probably downing it every bit of
30 [ __ ] beers all right
probably getting six hours sleep if I
was lucky I had season tickets to the
Patriots I abused my body on that day
and then I would finish it off every day
just eating a [ __ ] sausage king or a
slice of pizza just something horrific
and because I was young I had a
washboard middle I mean granted I was
working out but I'm at the age now I I
would I'd have to have be on a treadmill
the entire [ __ ] day that's just cruel
so if any of twenties enjoy it enjoy it
and develop some good [ __ ] eating
habits because those days don't last
right admit it old people don't you walk
into McDonald's sometimes and you're
feeling all [ __ ] guilty and you just
see some douchebags not even douchebags
you're just mad because they're young
and they're over there laughing having a
great time everybody's [ __ ] in shape
chowing down you know to make yourself
feel better you looking over there going
this for people over there you know what
statistically speaking one of them's
going to drop of a heart attack and I'm
still living so [ __ ] it it's not like I
started my life at this age I'm doing
alright right
yeah let me get the number three with a
root beer I'm sorry sir we don't have
it's sprite okay is sprite even remotely
like a root beer huh you did see [ __ ]
why wouldn't you say coke at least
they're both Brown alright sorry um
anyways this is the money morning
podcast I do one of these every single
week out of the goodness of my heart all
the horrific things I do all week long I
wash away all of them every Monday by
doing this podcast for my listeners
that's what I do that's why I do it this
is how I repent considering I don't go
to church anymore you know I haven't
been to confession confession how [ __ ]
up was that you go in there and you rat
yourself out to some other [ __ ]
douche bag and he's acting like he's
acting like oh you got you got to come
to me and then I'm gonna tell God like
God didn't watch everything that I just
did you know I could I could do that
[ __ ] in my bedroom you know what I mean
that's like yeah that's like when you
got old technology you don't I mean like
me I just bought an iPod not knowing
that phones are basically iPods now yeah
it's just stupid it's an extra [ __ ]
odd that's a terrible example what am I
trying to think of what am i it's like
they got why they got wireless mics now
for some reason I got a cord on this one
I could be walking all around my
apartment making me if making myself a
sandwich and I'm not that's another bad
example Jesus I'm gonna [ __ ] hold it
you know what I'm saying
I met a confession in a long time and
and I don't know I would actually like
to start going to church again what do
you think about that has anybody got any
good suggestions out there we got a
church where it's not the Catholic
Church it's not a church where the
person you're in church with started the
religion and it's somehow become a
christ-like figure and is trying to
brainwash you that it's okay for him to
start having sex with your children I
don't join a cult
okay somewhere between a cults in an
organized religion and I don't even
mister good vibe [ __ ] either
double why don't I start a church there
we go that's right cuz I'm not qualified
I don't know what you know what is I
like to discipline a church I was
speaking of that you know what dudes I
did say dudes what kind of [ __ ] still
says it you know what dudes
let me lay this one on you I did bought
the Bob and Tom show I've been on the
road for two weeks by the way this is
basically what happened I was working
Columbus Ohio and then I was going on to
work Caroline's in New York City so I
had back-to-back weeks on the road and
after that I can tell you what's
underrated you know what's underrated
sleeping and your own [ __ ] bed is
underrated having access to your entire
wardrobe is underrated being able to rub
one out and not have to put it please
don't clean the room now sign on your
door that's also that's also overrated
remembering what the [ __ ] you were
talking about that's overrated hey does
anybody have like a help young memory
like brain game that I can start playing
because I'm starting to really believe
that your brain is a muscle because I am
really losing my train of thought
at a disturbing amount every single day
now and I was just reading this story
about uh you know that Laster lady who
passed away in New York the Astor family
asked her place and all that type of
[ __ ] she I guess she got Alzheimer's and
it sounds like a [ __ ] horrific way to
go so I started thinking like well what
if I start playing pictionary what if I
go to Toys R Us and I buy that game
that's supposed to help kids memories
you know we got the cards you know and
you turn one over into an owl and you
try to find the other owl and then you
try it's an owl and then it's a basset
hound and you like [ __ ] you know then
your parents go I knew you weren't going
to amount to [ __ ] right remember that
game isn't there is there an adult
version of that that anybody can
recommend because seriously I I really
don't want to go out like that
does anybody staying up on that whole
Astro family [ __ ] thing with a guy
evidently was the son as well as the the
older Astro lady went into her senile
years he just started you know rewriting
her will so he get all the cash
that's a weird [ __ ] family the
Astor's it's like the whole that lady
lady just died a couple years ago she
gave away like 200 million dollars to
charity but if you look at how they got
this [ __ ]
they were slumlords like a century worth
of people died at tuberculosis and their
[ __ ] damp dark [ __ ] walk-in closet
apartments that they had and then after
a while they felt guilty so they started
giving it away but you know what I'm on
to your game never tell you my theory
about statues unless you're like an
artist an entertainer a sports person or
whatever you know if there's a statue of
you unless you're you're one of those
kinds of people
you did something [ __ ] up you know
doesn't make any sense to you like
Stevie Ray Vaughan got a statue right
what did he do he made albums he played
guitar I'm sure you heard some people
around him at some point you know swung
his guitar around the strap broke and he
[ __ ] smashed some chick in the teeth
maybe that happened you know I'm just
saying generally speaking he didn't hurt
anybody but he look at these other guys
you like who the [ __ ] is that guy
anytime okay this here is a fun exercise
next time you walk by a statue and
you're looking at like who the [ __ ] is
that guy go on the internet and just
google whatever his name is and then
write robber baron after it or some sort
of just write corrupt and google it and
watch all the [ __ ] articles you find
granted you know you're not really you
you know you know I never really googled
that you know the same name and great
guy I never do that either
because I just could have thought in my
head that's what a lot of people do when
they go on the Internet
you have a thought in your head what you
[ __ ] think somebody is or what the
[ __ ] going on and then you just google
[ __ ] and the way you google it it's so
everyone will support you you know like
if you think someone's an [ __ ] you're
like you know Brian Jones douche and
then you google and then all these
artists come up and then you go there
you go look at all the articles right
see he is a douche you know he's
supposed to just Google the guy's name
and then then
peace through him I never do that I'm
actually yelling at myself right now you
guys want to hear a story
um Oh before I get into that I got I got
I got a rectify something I said last
week you know I was talking about how
Pontiac went out of business and I was
saying the Trans Am was like their best
car and I was like what else did they
have after that it goes to the Sunbird
then the Pontiac t1000 there's a major
drop-off I stand corrected later on that
day I was laying in bed and I actually
sat upright now was I kind of [ __ ] that
I forget the Pontiac GTO you know the
Bonneville they had a lot of good cars
it's not the Aztec I'm looking right now
the top ten
Pontiacs of all time and they actually
put the Pontiac Aztek if that wasn't the
ugliest [ __ ] vehicle other than the
Chevy lumina remember that thing
Chevy [ __ ] Lumina all right so here's
something for you guys you want to you
want to look I'm really into cars and
that type of [ __ ] if you want to see one
of the most [ __ ] up looking vehicles
of all time Google this I'm not even
asking you I'm telling you google this
the GMC future liner all right and
however you spell it you're going to be
able to find it this was something that
they made in like the 1940s they had
this thing called the parade of progress
is a great YouTube video that's
something else you can google the parade
of progress and they had these I can't
even explain what they are
it'd be like picture of a toaster ate a
Winnebago that's what this [ __ ] thing
looks like are you looking it up right
now yet your desk you sitting there you
cubicle pretending like you're doing
your real work you got to look this
thing up I apologize to people on planes
right now or if you're on a treadmill
but you got to look this [ __ ] thing
up I wanna I I never even heard of these
things and I was watching one of those
Auto shows you know all those rich [ __ ]
go out and they spent two million
dollars in a Mustang so now I can't buy
one well this does actually more like
couple hundred thousand but this thing
actually went for like a million dollars
maybe even more and actually to look at
it from the side it looks like it has
four wheels but each wheel is doubled
you know like those dually pickups so
actually has eight wheels and like I
said it literally looks like the Jolly
Green Giant had a toaster with wheels on
it this is what the [ __ ] that thing
would look like but I don't think I
think 99% of Americans have never seen
this thing and if you ever had one of
those and just drove it down the [ __ ]
Street a bunch of people would look at
ya and isn't that isn't that what we're
all asking for everyone's going to look
in your direction to be like wow who's
that guy is he a rebel um alright I got
to read this [ __ ] up email before this
isn't even the podcast it's just me
bullshitting around here let me get into
uh here's a story somebody sent to me
which brings up an interesting debate
here says hey Bill my name is so-and-so
I'm just writing to let you know you're
my favorite comedian I really can relate
to everything you say not sure if that's
good or bad ello [ __ ] ell I bought
tickets to see you on Friday at
Caroline's in New York I spent over $200
on tickets about a month before so that
me and my friends could go and have a
grand old time well lo and behold
of course this [ __ ] only happens to me
we get on the train two hours before you
go on so we can get there plenty of time
and watch the show but lo and behold
what happens some [ __ ] lady decided
that she was going to end her life and
get hit by the train in front of mine I
know it's a sad thing and I should feel
bad but [ __ ] that I was like really lady
are you serious of all the [ __ ]
trains it had to be the one that I was
on that got delayed two hours I'm like
[ __ ] if you want to kill yourself
because you know because you're
miserable with your life go shoot
yourself a jump off a bridge but don't
make us all suffer so anyways long story
short only got to see the last thirty
minutes you show which was great but I
was disappointed that we couldn't see
the whole thing I'm not sure when you'll
be in New York again I'm sure your
website will post a post a day whenever
it will be while you're probably
wondering why the [ __ ] I'm writing you
well I have to vent to someone that's on
my level of understanding understanding
people suck
Jesus Christ well I'm sorry sorry to
hear that y'all you should have you
should have told me that story
you know I would have [ __ ] I would
have tossed you a DVD at the end what
are giving you something for your
troubles um you actually bring up a good
point you know if you're going to kill
yourself it's bad enough you're going to
make everyone around you suffer buddy
I'm a complete stranger suffer delay
their night have fun
what a [ __ ] way to go Jesus Christ I
can tell you right now there is no way
to do a thorough cleanup after somebody
jumps in front of a [ __ ] train
there's no [ __ ] way you're getting
every piece you know I mean there's no
way if you don't believe me why don't
you go get a flank steak and stick an
m-80 in it and light it off in your
kitchen clean it up to the best of your
ability and I guarantee you six months
from now you're going to be fine and
[ __ ] in the curtains you know there's
just uh and yeah for those of you didn't
wonder this is a very educational
podcast that's that's what like jumping
in front of a train is that's exactly
what it's like lighting off an m-80 in a
flank steak in a kitchen all right so
right now even if you press stop and you
never listen to the rest of this you
actually [ __ ] learn something all
right so here we go this is the podcast
this is what the [ __ ] I do I do it every
single Monday people send me questions
and information we have a list of stuff
that's overrated and underrated people
send me stories about revenge and all
that type of [ __ ] have I really been
talking for [ __ ] 20 minutes is that
true did I [ __ ] up again you know what
there's no way for me to know ah [ __ ] I
have to hit stop [ __ ] [ __ ] all right so
I [ __ ] up you know I thought I thought
geez I can't even tell you what the [ __ ]
I thought I can't even explain it I
thought I thought it was only three
minutes into the podcast I looked down
and said 19 minutes and I thought I
[ __ ] up I thought I started the
podcast at the end of another [ __ ] up
podcast and turned out I didn't so
there's just going to be two tracks this
week which a lot of us she should
probably enjoy on some level because a
number of you give me [ __ ] about how big
my files are oh the two too long to
download me well why don't you upload
upload upgrade your [ __ ] technology
and what do you want from me
I don't know how to do this [ __ ] stop
giving me [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] people every week people seem to
like last week when I was all hungover
so a lot of people said it was my best
podcast of all time but there was a
couple people who actually went out of
the way to tell me that they thought
that it sucked
you know don't do any more hungover
podcast okay I thought that one kind of
sucked women really didn't like it did I
say something really mean about women
because the only ones who didn't like it
were women you know I don't know if you
have drunk boyfriends you know or
spouses he was such a swell guy and then
after we got married everything was
going brick it was going great and then
one day at work he hurt his back and
then they started taking pain pills and
then he had an episode of intervention
you know so is that what it reminded you
of I wasn't trying to piss anyone off
all right um so anyways having survived
the epidemic in New York City the swine
flu epidemic I was so sick of them using
the words epidemic and pandemic you know
I was like what the [ __ ] is the
difference so basically an epidemic is
when you I guess it's some sort of
whatever it's some sort of disease or
some [ __ ] but it's confined its confined
to one country I guess and a pandemic is
global you know and if it's just in an
area in a country that's a breakout but
the definition of an epidemic ever
evidently what makes something an
epidemic according to Wikipedia I'm
saving you guys time you don't have to
look it up and read it because that's
where I get it from an epidemic is
basically uh it basically says defining
an epidemic can be subjective depending
in part on what is expected an epidemic
may be restrict restricted to one locale
an outbreak like I just said more
general and epidemic or even global
pandemic because it is based on what is
expected or thought normal a few cases
of a very rare disease like rabies may
be classified as an epidemic while many
cases of the common common diseases like
the common cold would not you know what
I mean
so basically
if you know five people had rabies out
here in LA that would be considered an
epidemic because that's five more than
they expected but if everybody had the
[ __ ] ass flu you know they'd be like
well you know we told them to wear
condoms um all right let's get to the
overrated underrated here for this week
uh overrated this guy sends in he said
uh Red Sox sweeping the Yankees in April
I thought that that was hilarious
because not only is that true it is just
April but what I really found funny is
that if the Yankees swept the Red Sox
that dude would not think that it was
overrated he would be like you see we
[ __ ] own you guys [ __ ] Boston you
guys [ __ ] suck everything closes by
1:00 this [ __ ] city so [ __ ] lame
can't even get a [ __ ] slice um I
don't think the Red Sox sweeping the
Yankees in April is overrated you know
you know I think is overrated spending
420 million dollars on three [ __ ]
guys what do you know about that that's
[ __ ] overrated spending two hundred
million dollars a year to not win the
World Series he's overrated
I don't understand why don't the Yankees
trust their farm system oh I know why
they don't trust him because all their
farm system has ever given them is Lou
Gehrig Joe DiMaggio Mickey Mantle Derek
Jeter Andy Pettitte Bernie Williams
Jorge Posada why the [ __ ] would you why
would you wait around to build a team
when you can go out and spend hundreds
of millions of dollars on [ __ ]
there I can't you [ __ ] him but they're
not gonna win it again this year
[ __ ] unbelievable I was sitting there
going to for 220 million dollars and
three guys there's no [ __ ] way you
know and Teixeira was on the angels last
year I mean that guy he looked like a
beast I don't know actually went to
Yankee Stadium on Sunday new Yankee
Stadium
I got a mitt I really had a lot of mixed
emotions as I as I got out there
I got off and I looked at old Yankee
Stadium I'm like that's Yankee Stadium
you know I'm a sentimental jackass I'm
into the history you know I loved going
into that place that [ __ ] place was
awesome you know even though so many
horrific things happen to the Red Sox
there it mean Jesus he'd be any sort of
a sports man you got it you got a
respect that that's the that's the
number one stadium in all four sports
without a doubt 26 [ __ ] championships
not even those [ __ ] sissies up in
Montreal can say that you know hey what
do you guys this question what do you
think's the most overrated team with
like like as far as let has like the
most amount of championships I was
talking to us with with a guy the other
day like you ever notice like in any
sort of league there's always like
there's always one team in the in the
inception of a league that always goes
on a run in the beginning and they go on
such a run that you know basically for
the most part it's going to take another
century to catch up with them if you
even can you know do you don't I'm
saying like look at the Celtics the
Celtics went on that run in the 60s it's
like come on man do you see what people
look like they barely were like that the
league just started you know what I mean
I mean you look at that [ __ ] the way
they play like I think I could have
[ __ ] made the final cut you know and
then you got the Yankees they they they
won way back a whole bunch back in the
Three Stooges era but I really don't
disrespect a baseball one once once they
let black people and Latinos in and that
type of [ __ ] the Yankees still [ __ ]
dominated but I think I might have to go
with the Canadians just for the simple
fact that there were only six teams you
know what I mean so I think it's kind of
easy much easier to go on a run in
hockey than it was in basketball or even
baseball because bet I think baseball
had like how many teams do they have
like Jesus I probably should've looked
this up I used to know this [ __ ] I think
they had about fit love 1460 and I was
like maybe twelve teams but here's
another thing too back in the day when
when you went to the world when if you
won the division that was winning the
panic you know and then you just
immediately went to the World Series
there wasn't [ __ ] a round of playoffs
before the World Series for a while
until they got past a certain amount of
teams and you know when a Stanley Cup he
had to win eight games that's a whole
nother [ __ ] deal you know what I mean
like nowadays like all these all these
teams there's like 30 teams and every
single [ __ ] league now so now you got
a one in thirty chance as opposed to
back in the day look at hockey you had a
one in six chance of winning the Cup and
it's something else I didn't notice
either the month that the Toronto Maple
Leaves hung with the Canadiens right up
til 1967 they were like neck-and-neck
they were like 15 Stanley Cups verse 13
[ __ ] Toronto was right there man and
then they just they just [ __ ] the bed my
whole life then I was born I think I'm
cursin the Toronto Maple Leafs um for
damages I'm you know what before the
Canadian fans get pissed I'm just
breaking your balls cuz I know you guys
you won like what you win seven cups in
the 70s is that what you did I think you
did and that was with the expansion
twelfth but even that was [ __ ] cuz
then they took the expansion six and
they just put him in their own [ __ ]
division so then all you had to do was
just when the other division and then
you went up against like the [ __ ] st.
Louis Blues like we did like the North
Stars or some [ __ ] alright that last
three minutes was for the [ __ ] Sports
nerds alright let me move on here all I
didn't say so I went in to new Yankee
Stadium and I I gotta admit like I don't
know man I I it was I got it was weird
because you were looking at the Yankees
I felt like I was at legends field you
know I was like those are the New York
Yankees but this is not their house I
don't feel I don't feel the history you
know um I also kinda made it kind of
looked like every other [ __ ] stadium
except it had that cool facade the
facade is the [ __ ]
outside of the stadium is the ship and
inside it just kind of has like [ __ ]
voice cracks inside inside the stadium
it just kind of look like I don't know I
think I might like Pac Bell a little
better I'll have to go again you know
what some amazing [ __ ] has to happen
there Fred that's that's the same all of
those [ __ ] things I can just go to
Shea Stadium
and even after the Red Sox wanted I
would still look at that spot with a
boat well the ball went through
Buckner's legs except after we wanted
then it would then I also saw the humor
in it but until then till that point I
didn't all right moving on here all
right the other thing that people say is
overrated the people's people's Kentucky
Derby picks I hate all these people who
basically only watch three horse races a
year they only watch three horse races a
year yet they they give me they come up
to me and they give you a G you know
something half this isn't [ __ ] me you
know what I was actually gonna blame the
guy who [ __ ] wrote that but I can't
you know that's actually how I've read
it all right let me let me start over
again
people's Kentucky Derby picks I hated
how all these people who basically only
watch three races a year yet yet no you
did [ __ ] up yet they give you their
Derby picks and they say [ __ ] like it's
going to be a sloppy track today
this horse thrives on a sloppy track
does he you know what that was such a
great [ __ ] point I really butchered
that yeah I know everybody starts acting
like they're [ __ ] Jack Klugman you
know with a rolled-up program nobody
gives a [ __ ] about horse races you know
back in the day horse racing and boxing
used to be the number one sports granted
there was no football baseball in hockey
basketball none of that [ __ ] was around
then one was around it took a while for
it to take over this is just all going
to be sports this week pay-per-view
boxing matches are overrated they're
never worth the money it's just all
about the marking I'm glad I didn't
spend $50 on the hat and pocky was it
Pacquiao Pacquiao fight because it was
on YouTube for free about two hours
later although I will buy Pacquiao or
Pacquiao Javy say his name Mayweather if
that happens well that's good to know
sir
underrated how gay those frilly boxing
trunks some fighters wear I think it's I
think it's see this is the [ __ ] I can't
read it cuz it's too [ __ ] small going
I'm getting old here I think it sells
hysterical when some fighters come out
wearing some something Liberace
would where and then they just get the
[ __ ] beat out of them
this guy really wrote some funny [ __ ]
I'm just butchering it I guess I could
never be a [ __ ] newscaster let me try
that again
okay underrated how gay those frilly
boxing trunks some fighters wear see if
that's a fragment that's what trips me
up should say how gay some of those
frilly boxing trunks are that some of
the fighters wear I think it's
hysterical when some when a fighter
comes out wearing something that only
Liberace would wear and then he goes on
to get this [ __ ] kicked out of him
hey that's what I'll do I'll get the
gist of it I'll just paraphrase
underrated massages with happy endings
for a hundred bucks you get a 60-minute
massage that ends with an agent an asian
chick beating you off and to top it off
at the end for no extra charge she'll
give you a table shower which is
basically a bath it's how God must get a
[ __ ]
dude you write really funny [ __ ] I mean
I'm not telling you to go out there and
you might you might get a future this
son this Sonny Boy hey getting back to
the the the swine-flu [ __ ] it was a
bunch of people walking around New York
with those masks on those little
surgical masks how [ __ ] hilarious is
that it's an airborne virus I don't
understand the thought process you're
breathing through the mask what is it
what is the oxygen gets through but not
the pig virus see oxygen is just a wee
bit smaller than the pig virus pig virus
just hits the front of the mask and then
that's it I was on my flight today
flying out here from New York City and
this is sort of weird and I want to know
from my my Asian constituents whatever
the [ __ ] word is um there was about
six people on the plane who are all
wearing those surgical masks like they
were going to amputate somebody's leg
during the Civil War or doing a [ __ ]
guest star on mash they were wearing
blue and they were all Asian only the
agents were wearing those and what is
that from was that because they had to
live through SARS and and they made it
by the grace of God but there's so for
some reason like attributing the
mash - it does anybody know does anybody
know out there anybody anybody out there
in podcast land alright I have to do the
[ __ ] math here up to 29 minutes not
to go too long all right by the way bill
congratulations on the Celtics beating
the Bulls but I want to know how you
feel about Derrick Rose just basically
bitch-slapping Brian Scalabrine in game
7 with that nasty-ass block considering
we won the series I think I feel pretty
fine about it I actually did a show that
night and I miss game 7 but uh you guys
are going to be great man you guys have
a great young team and that guy Brian
Scalabrine is that the [ __ ] dude who
looks like Jesus Christ I always forget
his [ __ ] name what is that act his
[ __ ] name I always think Michael
Madsen and then that screw on Matthew
Modine I always think there's an M in it
you know the guy he was in Copland he
played the cop that had to disappear uh
what is his [ __ ] name that's exactly
what that [ __ ] dude looks like [ __ ]
he started that that short-lived sitcom
the war at home actually admit lasted a
season so that's actually successful
these days the way they cancel him the
[ __ ] is his name I swear to god man I'm
like literally losing my mind here
now we have to google it I have to take
time out of the [ __ ] podcast that I
have typed with one hand because I'm
holding my Monday Night Football [ __ ]
microphone here the war at home doesn't
sign keep trying to uh Michael Rapaport
there we go that's how he looks like he
looks like Michael Rapaport I went to
that Celtics Utah Jazz game out in Utah
where Garnett got hurt and that Michael
Rapaport dude I watched him have one
foul in the first half and then he
fouled out in the third quarter in the
span I swear to god of four minutes I
haven't seen any [ __ ] like that since
Darryl Dawkins and I swear to god that's
the end of the sports [ __ ] all right for
the rest of you here we go we're going
to move on here uh moving on to the next
part of the podcast where the [ __ ] am I
okay somebody wants my advice dear bill
I guess this falls under the I need
advice column of the podcast my 30th
birthday is four days before your 41st
according to Wikipedia and I gotta admit
that I'm not looking forward to it I
just feel like I'm getting old and it
sucks I work with this kid who's 23 and
one day a couple weeks ago I caught
myself in the middle of a speech about
how lucky he is to be 23 and how as a
dude that's the perfect age 23 years old
all I recall I could remember was at
that age I had [ __ ] falling out of my
pockets and let's just say things have
dried up since then I promptly shut the
hell up when I realized I was starting
to sound like my dad but the kid was
actually listening to me and asking
questions about typical guys [ __ ] so
basically what I'm asking is what advice
would you please offer to me about
relationships and life in general you
know like if I knew what I knew what I
know now kind of [ __ ] thanks in advance
all right so obviously dude your
relationships aren't working out so
you've made the the brilliant decision
to ask someone who's never made a
relationship work actually my
relationship now is working right what
is the advice Jesus Christ where the
[ __ ] do I start
be selfish there you go that's a good
one I mean in your dating I'm literally
tangled up in the [ __ ] wires here all
right that's what you're gonna do you
got to be selfish and before you start
date before you get back out just just
make a list of [ __ ] that you want you
know like practical [ __ ] don't be like
big kids [ __ ] round as she's got to
have nice toes uh you know what else and
what the [ __ ] else is there nice face
you know dress is nice but not a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know I'm saying um you gotta have
some other [ __ ] too I don't I mean I
haven't been able to get married yet so
that seems to be the pinnacle of what
makes a healthy relationship for some
[ __ ] reason but I did have a buddy of
my
and who was a complete [ __ ] maniac
and he got married and I asked him how
he went about doing it he just said he's
just he dumped all the [ __ ] you know
you know all those girls you got in your
cell phone as much as you saying the
dried up you know you got all those
numbers in your cell phone you know
those numbers those numbers you only
call it 1:30 two o'clock in the morning
you know those girls
you gotta sever ties with those girls
because it's just it's too [ __ ] easy
it's like it's like junk food you got it
laying around in your house you're gonna
become if you're just gonna he's gonna
eat it you open the bag eat the whole
[ __ ] thing then you sitting there
going why the [ __ ] did I do that you
know then I write a blog lub I wrote a
blog about that how [ __ ] are like the
the human equivalent to a [ __ ] bag of
Doritos um how the [ __ ] is it 19 minutes
again what's 19 and 1938 there we go
okay I got 12 minutes here um yeah so
just really figure out what the [ __ ] you
want and this guy one of the great
things he did was he if he found out a
beat found out a girl he was dating one
of the first questions he'd ask is if
her parents were still together and if
they were still together
he'd there would be a second date and if
there weren't still together there
wasn't a second date and I know a lot of
people get offended about that [ __ ] but
that's a great way to get a pure-bred
you know other [ __ ] you know I don't
know you just got to make a list of what
the [ __ ] you want but you really got to
stop you got to stop [ __ ] with the
horse and it's a hard thing it's
definitely a hard thing and jeez I'm
just I'm a little jet-lagged here dude
if you ask me something a little more
space on you ask me specific things
because if you ask me an overall
question like that all right what else
can I come on Bill think all right
everybody's nuts including you and so
you got to you got to find you got to
pick someone that complements your crazy
you don't I mean you can't and you won't
you think you want to get somebody who's
the same kind of crazy so then you guys
relate to each other but that's that's
not good because then you're both going
batshit at the same time
and when that happens you neither one of
you have anybody to call to bail you out
of the holding cell you know what I mean
um what else jesus [ __ ] christ
don't date those girls who say they used
to be a [ __ ] but now they're not don't
date those girls um what else I don't
[ __ ] I'll do it I'm I'm really trying
here you know what to write write me
back next week ask me something more
specific
I'm just really go I'm going blank here
I'm really I'm really choking on this
one I usually have a ton of [ __ ] to say
why is my [ __ ] software updates are
available for your computer do you want
to install them now I'm doing a [ __ ]
podcast not now ah [ __ ] well you know
what if anybody else out there has some
[ __ ] advice to give them obviously I
got I got nothing I only have advice
about how to get out of relationships
like that dude that one time it was
asking me and you want the biggest thing
I had to email him back I forgot to tell
him was when he was getting away from
that just to do a recap he was with this
girl she had a couple kids with another
guy and he was kind of in the
relationship with her and he was semi
passed out when he was drunk and when he
woke tup she was [ __ ] flirting with
with his best friend so he's trying to
get out of the relationship and I told
him basically he knew what he needed to
do but I forgot the number-one thing
that I I forgot to tell him was under no
circumstances should he ever [ __ ] that
girl again
you got to watch out for those girls
that already have kids by somebody else
you really got to watch out in general
you got to watch out during that breakup
time you really got to watch out because
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] people go
nuts guys and women go nuts guys could
get physical they could start stalking
you they go that route women can get
crazy and accidentally take themselves
off the [ __ ] pill and some sort of
[ __ ] up desperation either to keep it
going or even worse some sort of
vengeance thing they're just not
thinking clearly and then they get
knocked up and next thing you know
they're thinking clearly and they don't
want the [ __ ] kid either and you
joined to the hip so where
a [ __ ] condom that's another thing to
wear a [ __ ] condom and uh yeah do
that [ __ ] wear a condom you know that's
another good thing too if you get with a
girl and she you know starts asking you
if you've been tested and that type of
[ __ ] that's a good thing you want a
Bronx Tale like lock the door test hook
up with the girl all right and when you
get ready to do the deed
don't bring up a condom and if she
doesn't flinch you know stand up and
just walk out with your hard-on no one
has the [ __ ] strength to do that but
at least for the love of God [ __ ] put
one on alright that's it do that that
advice really sucked I'm telling you
just ask me something more specific I'll
try to help you out all right let's get
to the final thing that I'm going to do
this week a little jet lag this week and
it's hot as [ __ ] in this room for some
reason I can't open the goddamn windows
because and I picks up every sound from
the street last week I actually asked a
question about how to change the default
on my computer for the size of the font
when I type out my files because I'm
really bad at computers and somebody
actually helped me out with it like that
day it's really simple if you're in
Apple work she go to edit
up on the toolbar there you click on
edit if I can do it right now click on
edit and what do you wait what the [ __ ]
this doesn't make sense go to edit no
you don't click on Apple works that's
what you want to do go on Apple works
and you click on prevalence province
preferences all right let me start up
again you go to Apple works click on
that you go into preferences and then
you click on general and let's see if I
can do this here oh yeah then you see
your default size is right there and
then you just click on the [ __ ] arrow
and you can pick one other size and then
you hit OK that's how you do it I know
that's very basic if you guys have some
more difficult [ __ ] questions you
want to ask them on this podcast I will
read them and this computer nerds out
there that cannot wait to [ __ ] help
you what else do we got here I think I
think I just have a [ __ ] hangover
story and then our vengeance thing wow
I'm really losing momentum here I don't
know what to do it's like the beginning
of [ __ ] Six Million Dollar Man you
know when that little [ __ ] kite that
he's flying why don't they ever show
that [ __ ] show in reruns that's one
of the greatest goddamn shows ever do
you guys ever see that
do you have any idea how [ __ ] huge it
was when the Six Million Dollar Man
fought the seven Million Dollar Man and
he punched his [ __ ] face off his face
came off on television in like 1974 do
you have any [ __ ] idea think about
that pre internet pre cable pre any sort
of special affected you look how bad the
graphics were in Star Wars this is like
three four years before that Lee Majors
punched this dude who was the [ __ ]
bad guy in everything oh man do you
remember the one with a Six Million
Dollar Man fired up fought in the snow
outside that mansion they had everybody
in slow motion and that black dude
jumped like ten feet in the air was
going to kick him he's gonna walk
flying through the [ __ ] air now you
understand how sheltered I was as a kid
I don't even know who Bruce Lee was I
didn't know what kung-fu fighting was
and I didn't realize that TV shows were
ripping off you know Enter the Dragon
and all that [ __ ] that people were
flipping out about because I was just a
little kid so I saw that [ __ ] I was the
most unbelievable thing ever he fought
Bigfoot he fought a black Bruce Lee and
he fought the 7 Million Dollar Man and
he punched his [ __ ] face off and tell
they they just don't they don't make
it's impossible to compete now that's
just they've just done too many things
you know it's kind of like when you go
to write a movie script like
everything's been done and they act like
all these guys back in the 40s and 50s
were brilliant it's like [ __ ] you there
was only like 5 movies were ever made
how hard was it to be brilliant back
then
it's like inventing [ __ ] knee in the
1800s look it's a coat hanger you can
hang your coat on it holy [ __ ] let's put
his name in the history books everyone
can [ __ ] remember this for the rest
of the time I don't even know what you
could invent you know is great it's
still inventing simple [ __ ] is that
Billy Mays guy you know that bear dude
[ __ ] every night he just starts sob
Billy Mays that dude he doesn't even
invent the [ __ ] I think he invented like
three things and then he's just got a
sweat shop of like smart [ __ ] kids
from Thailand and he just comes walking
in I keep bar to myself on the iron come
up with some [ __ ] then like three weeks
later he's on TV I'm Billy Mays are you
tired of burning the hair off your
forearm when you're ironing your
button-down because your third marriage
didn't work out and you still have to
date in your 50s introducing the [ __ ]
thing you stick in front of the iron
that doesn't burn your forearm but still
irons the [ __ ] shirt um anyways oh
let me get let me get back to this thing
sorry that's like that there you go I
wanted to stand up mo give you some
[ __ ] laughs okay all right hang over
here let me get let me get back to here
so here's a hangover last week I did I
did a podcast where I had a hangover
and somebody gave me some sort of uh
Jesus can you tell him stalling for time
because I went to the wrong [ __ ]
place advice I gave that guy horrible
advice um alright yeah I was kind of
[ __ ] hungover last week so I had
somebody give me advice on how to cure a
hangover and this is what I got here's a
grace here's a great hangover tip works
for me most of the time eat a greasy
breakfast with all the coffee you can
[ __ ] stomach the morning after
drinking I recommend Waffle House or
some other piece-of-shit diner you know
what some people you know what I've
always heard the greasy breakfast thing
people actually had some other ones I
had never heard of and I evidently I
didn't [ __ ] I didn't save those oh
well well we're gonna end the podcast
right here we're going to end with a
revenge story alright uh alright bill
sometimes revenge comes when you least
expect it I like that this person
started their revenge story with this
that sounds like a great trailer for a
for a summer blockbuster you know Tom
Hanks meg Ryan and some other douchebag
that you don't give a [ __ ] star in the
revenge sometimes revenge comes when you
least expect it alright I'm my older
brother Jamie had always teased me about
something since it had happened when I
was about 15 but I can't tell you what
it was because it will ruin the rest of
the story but I had my day of revenge
alright
fast-forward to fast-forward eight years
I was managing a rock band full time and
my brother was about to move out to LA
to take a shot at acting so he had moved
out of his apartment was temporary
temporarily crashing up the street from
my place at a mutual friend's apartment
we all lived in these apartments in a
small town in South Jersey me and one of
the guys from the band were living in an
apartment that was connected to a house
of a family we sort of grew up with they
had a son Charlie who was our age but
had Down syndrome so we still lived at
home
Charlie would always seemed to pop in to
our apartment at the worst times you
know in like the middle of parties when
we were smoking pot or maybe when I was
on the couch with a girl trying to get
laid
he just had this timing where he would
show up at the exactly the wrong time on
this particular Sunday afternoon I
called my brother to let him know we had
ordered some pizzas and sandwiches and
he could come over and have some have
some if he wanted we had all been
drinking heavily the night before as me
and the band were out out of town on
tour my brother got perfectly blunted I
think he was supposed to try to say the
previous night and I knew he'd be see
this is what sucks about this small
[ __ ] font please write him bigger
type guys I wasn't gonna put my face
right up to the goddamn screen you guys
are making me blind here
all right my brother got [ __ ] up the
other night and I knew he'd be on our
buddies couch just hate in life but when
I called him up he was being a [ __ ] and
asked if I could actually bring the
[ __ ] food over to him you guys
understand what's going on here they're
all hungover his brother word is some
pizzas and now the goodness of his heart
he calls his brother up the street and
the [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] said can you can
you bring it over so this so this dude
like a normal person says [ __ ] no I
bought the food I'm offering you some if
you want it just come over but he
couldn't get off the couch now I'm
Charlie the Down syndrome kid who must
have seen the pizza delivery guy knocked
on our door minutes later my roommate
Tom and I then thought of something fun
to do Charlie actually really liked my
brother
they were always messing around but if
you ever if you ever hung out with the
kid with Down syndrome that usually
means he wants to fight or write you a
wrestle this is reminding me of
something about Mary since my brother
was being such a lazy turd and wouldn't
come over we thought it would be funny
to have Charlie deliver the pizza to
Jamie since we knew Charlie I guess
Jamie's his brother excuse me um
whatever have Charlie delivered to Jamie
since we knew Charlie would immediately
want to wrestle and [ __ ] around with him
constant consequently would make his
hangover much [ __ ] worse so anyways
our mutual friends with with us and he
had the key to the apartment where my
brother was staying on the couch we all
walked over to the apartment and down
the hall to the living room where my
brother was on the couch with the back
of the couch towards the door and the TV
facing us we immediately
realize that my brother was watching a
nasty nasty porno and was beating off
Jesus Christ I started to say hey here's
your pizza and then I was like oh no but
Charlie Charlie bursts past me and my
brother's stuck his head up over the
back of the couch before he knew it
Charlie used all of his [ __ ] strength
to give Jamie the haymaker of a lifetime
to the back of his head
my brother was dazed and utterly
confused he stood up and had on only an
old half shirt from high school football
and white socks and oh yeah he had a
raging hard-on
now Charlie is coming at him full go and
my brother's looking at us to stop
Charlie but we're all laughing too hard
and none of us were going to go anywhere
near that situation Charlie okay I mean
when you would you break up a fight
between a nearly naked guy with a boner
and kid with Down syndrome where would
you start
Charlie was not quitting
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and he's put on
his best move was to punch your balls
Jesus Christ dude this really happened
it sounds [ __ ] crazy he was coming at
Jamie with everything he had my brother
was just trying to hold him off till his
heart or hard-on subsided and he could
gather himself meanwhile the TV is still
on all loud and some nasty old fat chick
was getting banged in the ass by some
black dude it was complete mayhem it all
happened so fast
finally my brother pushed Charlie away
far enough to grab his shorts and put
them on Charlie was really tired was
really fired up because we'd give him
him giving him a big glass of Pepsi
beforehand and I was not supposed to
have caffeine well that's that's a great
thing to do
ahh buh buh buh buh buh um anyways my
brother would oh okay so this is
basically this is the thing he was
talking about what his brother used to
tease him up he said my brother would
always used to tease me about the time
he caught me beep beating off when I was
15 he was like a true older brother -
older brother dick about it and would
bring it up in front of other girls
family and whoever and just kept me I
just kept doing it for years after the
time the [ __ ] beat him up while he was
whacking off he never mentioned it again
Cheers Jesus
- did that did that all really happen um
sorry about saying [ __ ] - I never say
that [ __ ] he just had written and I try
to say [ __ ] Down syndrome as much as
I could
there you go you found a line I usually
don't say that [ __ ] anyway so that's the
podcast for the week I know it was
pretty [ __ ] uh it's pretty [ __ ] up
you know you got a 19-minute one and you
got a 35-minute once what does that make
that makes for most that's like almost
55 [ __ ] minutes I'm going to be at
The Improv here in Los Angeles in May I
don't know what weekend yet I believe
it's the weekend of May 20-something and
other than that we're going to be
filling in some standup dates and that's
it thank you guys for listening to the
Monday morning podcast please keep the
questions coming and coming and I
apologize I was a little bit jet-lagged
that's two [ __ ] weeks in a row you
know hungover last week
jet lag this week but you know what the
[ __ ] do you want from me it's called the
Monday morning podcast and I have to do
it on this day so so there you go I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I'll talk to you
next week alright see you next week
alright